So, ich muss mal mein Headset entknoten kurz.
So, auf gehts.
Hat Twitch schon gescheckt, dass der Stream on ist?
Ok, jetzt wird die Musik grad entwenig exquisite.
Ja, jetzt hat Twitch gecheckt, dass der Stream on ist.
Leute, Hacker Mode aktiviert.
Hallo, Chat.
Ne, Moment, wie muss ich winken?
So muss ich winken, oder?
Ja, dass man was sieht.
Hallo, Chat.
Ja, ich hab gedacht, wenn ich die Kamera und den Tisch und den ganzen Krempel schon mal
hier stehen hab, dann können wir das auch heute noch mal für was verwenden.
Oh Leute, ich muss doch schnell was zu trinken holen.
Ne, ne, das...
Eins, eins kann ich euch sagen, es gibt zwei Sachen, die müsst ihr machen.
Leona, 97, 18 Monate, dankeschön für den Sub, das ist Hyper Subscription, aber hier
mal...
Massive Life Hack, übrigens, Teams hat wieder mal Sound verstellt, ne?
Ah, yes.
Teams sackt einfach nur Hardcore.
So, genau, wie gesagt, ich geh jetzt erstmal schnell was zu trinken holen.
Es gibt uns Salami-E-Mode, ja, Wuppwurst, also, es gibt zwei Sachen, Huge Life Hack, Toxy,
dankeschön für die 13 Monate Subscription, und zwar, es gibt zwei Sachen, die ihr unbedingt
machen müsst, wenn ihr den ganzen Tag am Rechner sitzt, so wie ich, auch auf der Arbeit, jetzt
danach noch mal.
Ihr müsst einmal am Tag mindestens eine Stunde rausgehen, euch bewegen, ohne Scheiß, ich
hätte nie gedacht, dass ich das mal sage, aber das ist wirklich nicht ohne, sonst kriegt
man Kopfweh, es tut einem den Rücken, der Rücken weh und alles sackt, ja, und ihr müsst
viel trinken.
Jetzt kriegt ihr nämlich auch Kopfweh und es sackt auch, ordentlich trinken und am Tag
eine Stunde draußen rumlaufen, reicht schon, ihr müsst keine krassen Sport-Men-Rumgesprinte
machen, also, eine Stunde am Tag raus und sich ein bisschen bewegen und trinken.
Krasse Fitness-Tipps bei mir, ich weiß, aber das hilft wirklich, also, wenn ihr Rückenschmerzen
habt, wenn ihr Kopfschmerzen habt, wenn ihr irgendwas habt, bevor ihr anfängt, auch wenn
ihr hohen Blutdruck habt, was auch immer, bevor ihr anfängt und irgendwelche Pillen
nehmt oder sowas, geht eine Stunde am Tag raus, bewegt euch ein bisschen an der Luft
und trinkt ordentlich was.
So, gut, gut, dass ich das jetzt mal losgeworden bin, Leute, Chat, ich gehe jetzt mal kurz
was zu trinken holen, wo wir gerade beim Thema sind, dann bin ich wieder da, by the way,
Band-Emote, Anzeige ist raus, gleich wieder da, ich hänge fest, nur mein Headset.
Also, ich bin jetzt übelst die Treppe raufgesprindet, also, ich hab so, pass mal auf, guck mal,
ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das, mal gucken, ob ihr das auf der Kamera seht, ich geh mal kurz
ins Vollbild, ich hab hier so eine Falte im Teppich und da hakt das mit meinem, das übrigens
scheppt die Kamera, ne, da hakt das übelst mit meinem Stuhl, wenn ich da drüber fahr,
wackelt glaub ich die ganze Kamera, ja, guck mal, nur wenn ich mit dem Stuhl über die
Falte im Teppich fahr.
So, wir müssen mal gucken, dass ein Busy grad wird, warte mal, ich mach mal den Teppich
auf die Kamera, dann mach ich die Kamera grad, auf die Kamera, dann mach ich den Teppich
auf die Kamera, also, der Teppich ist wirklich äußerst stabil, was nicht stabil ist, ist
der Boden, das ist hier kein super massives Betonzeug, was der Opa da gebastelt hat, also,
guck mal, wenn ich jetzt Pepo Fett hier springe, das ist nicht der Tisch, guck mal, das ist
nicht der Tisch der wackelt, sondern das ist wirklich der Boden der wackelt und dementsprechend
wackelt der Tisch halt auch.
So, also, das kann man ein bisschen grad machen, das hier ist Schäpp, ach nee, da ist so diese
komischen Dinger, glaub, der abisoliert Schämpf ist auch am Start, ne, ist ja noch Schäpper,
ihr wollt jetzt noch Schäpper, ok, eigentlich ist es relativ, was ist denn ihr Schäpp jetzt,
was ist das da, so, ist es jetzt, Leute, ist es jetzt weniger Schäpp, ja, der Mauszeiger,
da kann ich grad nichts machen, der Mauszeiger springt immer in die Mitte und ich bin grad
nicht am Rechner, ich schieb grad den Kram, übrigens heute kein Holzfällerhemd, also,
das muss jetzt, ja, ich hab mir den, guck mal hier, das ist wirklich der Boden der wackelt,
natürlich trägt er auch ein bisschen dazu bei, dass ich jetzt nicht pepo leichtgewischt
bin, aber Elefant auch nicht, ja, ich hab mir den Switch geholt und im letzten Stream
haben wir uns den Switch sogar mal angeguckt, im Detail, Detail, im Detail haben wir uns
den angeguckt, so, also, ich hab mir folgendes gekauft, ich hab gedacht, das gucken wir uns
halt mal im Stream zusammen, ich hab mir einen Raspberry Pi 4 Flirck Case gekauft, beste,
und wir probieren das jetzt mal, hm, wisst ihr was noch richtig pro wär, wenn ich es
irgendwie hinkriegen würde, dass das Overlay auf beiden Desktops ist, das ist man Jaro
Linux mit i3 WM, ja, ich mein, ich kann einfach, ich kann einfach den Stream zweimal aufmachen,
so, okay, das ist sproken, Leute, RIP, zweimal starten im gleichen Browser geht nicht, aber
wir sind ja nice, der Hacker, man, wir machen jetzt einfach in Chrome auf, und im Chrome
kann ich es bestimmt noch mal starten, wie auch nicht, daher, im Chrome kann ich es noch
mal starten, null wie, oder, oder, Paints Champ, Post Champ, Post Champ, aber das geht
noch, oder, ja, okay, was auch immer, vielleicht kann man nicht mehr als drei Verbindungen
oder so machen, kann ja sein, Sticky Window, die dann auf jedem Workspace zu sehen, wirklich,
ja, du meinst diese, du meinst diese Scratchpad-Dinger, echt, wirklich, das, oh nice, nice, zeigst
mal her, das müssen wir jetzt gerade mal ausprobieren, Sticky, ne, Shift, ne, wie ist das, wie ist
das andere Stack, Stack, also bei mir ist Stacking, Stacking brauch ich eh nicht, und jetzt Sticky,
wirklich, geht das, hab ich noch nie ausprobiert, also das heißt, wenn ich jetzt dieses Fenster
hier nehme und sag, Windows S, Windows S, ach ne, Layout weg, Sticky Toggle, okay, wenn
ich jetzt dieses Fenster nehm, sag Picture in Picture, und sag jetzt Windows, Windows
S, boah, Alter, Massive Brained hier, ist das das ja geil, richtige Hacker-Man, guckt
euch das mal an, boah, ist das Poker so besser als OBS-Layout, der Chat ist wieder too smart
für die Welt, aber die Leute haben einfach gesagt, das ist der High IQ, der ist nur möglich
gewesen durch, wie viel Subs hab ich denn eigentlich aktuell, zeig mal, jetzt wieder
ein bisschen runtergegangen in dem Monat, aber ich glaub's immer noch relativ viel, 321,
ja, guck mal, es gab 321 mal IQ um 1 plus 1, komm mit, Dankeschön für den Twitch-Prime-Sub,
d.h. wir haben jetzt im Durchschnitt, wenn man davon ausgeht, Durchschnitts-IQ ist 100,
haben wir jetzt 421 IQ, da kann man solche Sachen schon mal drauf kommen, der Keks ist
ein 3D, das ist das da, das ist das, der da, das ist ein 3D gedruckter Keks, so sieht's
aus, Turbo-Dead-End, Sub'n und dann Instant-Prüfung bestehen, so ist es, genau, so sieht's aus,
also ich hab mir dieses Case hier gekauft und wir werden jetzt das folgende machen,
das was wir schon mal gemacht haben, und zwar wir flashen jetzt den Raspberry Pi mit einer
ordentlichen SSD diesmal, ich hab hier schon, guckt mal, Massive-SSD liegen, Big Brain-SSD,
Samsung, hallo, kann man das vielleicht mal irgendwie ordentlich dahinter, Samsung Endurance-SSD
64G, Leute, ich glaube ich spiegel mich auf der SD, MonkaS, beste, beste Micro-SD, hast
du noch was mit dem Mikro-Text gebastelt, ja, da steht, da, guck, den verwenden wir heute
als Switch für den Raspberry Pi, ja, ich sag manchmal Micro-SD und SSD verwechsel ich
manchmal ein bisschen, aber ihr wisst was ich mein, ja, hier, Chat, Massive, also die
sind wirklich nice, ausruggelt, habt ihr das gesehen, die verwenden wir heute, ich pack
die mal, ich pack die mal kurz aus, eigentlich müssen wir da gar nicht ins Vollscreen schalten,
oder, wenn ich die Dinger auspack, sieht man doch, wenn es klein ist, genauso, ich mein,
und außerdem, ihr müsst mir nicht beim Auspacken zugucken, wer hat eigentlich, jetzt mal ernsthaft,
wer hat eigentlich den, kann man das eigentlich vergrößern, boah, guckt, alter, ist das Big
Brain, das ist ja Massive, huge, guckt euch das mal an, was aus, jetzt hat es geruckelt,
was für ein geiles Zeug, mein Problem ist, ich hab keine Schere, doch, ich hab ne Schere,
Meinung zu Linux Minia kann man verwenden, also was ich ja nicht verstehe ist, warum,
wenn man, wenn man Micro SD Karten verpackt, Leute, oder, Micro SD Karten verpackt, ähm,
warum macht man da nochmal ne Plastik, ne Plastik Layer dazwischen, dass man das nicht
einfach aufreißen kann, was haben die sich denn da überlegt, weil guck, man kann den
Scheiß nicht, das geht nicht, man kann den nicht aufreißen, weil da ist so ein Plastik
Layer dazwischen, also, ich weiß, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das eigentlich offiziell
aufmacht, wenn nicht mit der Schere, weil man kann das irgendwie auseinanderreißen
oder so, aber das sagt doch alles, das muss man eigentlich mit ner Schere ausschneiden,
so, Diebstahlschutz, äh, das ist kein Diebstahlschutz, weil man kann, man muss das aufschneiden,
anders kriegt man das nicht auf, die haben sogar hier extra sowas eingeplant, wo man
aufschneiden muss, so, jetzt hol ich mal die olle Schere von der Oma, exellent, das ist
auch übelste Verschwendung, finde ich, dass bei jeder Micro SD Karte dieses Ding hier
dabei ist, dieser Adapter, der ist auch total useless, wie findest du das neue Lied von
Flair, ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, ich hab noch nicht ein Lied von Flair gehört, also
die einzigen deutschen Hip-Hop Sachen, die ich kenne, das sind ein paar Sachen von Haftbefehl,
äh, es ruckelt ein bisschen, ne, wie gesagt, Goethe-Straße, Louis Vuitton-Store, zahl
die Kollektion bar, fick auf Sponsor, einzige deutsche Deutschrap-Quote, was ich kann,
Moneyboy kenne ich auch, die ein oder anderen Sachen, aber ich mag absolut keinen Hip-Hop,
für mich ist gerade deutschsprachiger Hip-Hop und generell so, das einzige internationale
Hip-Hop Zeug, was ich mir tatsächlich gut geben kann, war früher mal Eminem, aber so
richtiger Hip-Hop Fan war ich noch nie, und für mich ist, wahrscheinlich sind jetzt wieder
übelst viel offended, weil es ist ja modern offended zu sein, ähm, für mich ist Hip-Hop
übelste Low-Brain-Musik, also wenn der Sub IQ++ gibt, gibt jedes Hip-Hop-Lied IQ minus
minus, empfiehlst du immer noch C-Sharp als beste Programmiersprache? Ne, ich sag nicht,
dass C-Sharp prinzipiell die beste Programmiersprache ist, ich sag, dass C-Sharp meine Lieblingsprogrammiersprache
ist, und, und, ähm, sie ist halt, sie ist halt super für alle möglichen Anwendungen,
ja und übrigens, Hip-Hop ist das 10++ der Musik, ja das, das, das kommt ungefähr hin,
das trifft, das trifft's eigentlich ganz gut, Dis-Abo, nicht De-Abo Leute, als richtig
krasser Gangster-Rapper-Hörer müsstest du eigentlich wissen, dass es Dis-Abo heißt,
Dis-De-Abo, ähm, wann machst du wieder Stream zusammen mit Allotricks? Ja, wir, wir streamen
ja auch sonst so oft zusammen, es ist jetzt wirklich mal an der Zeit, dass wir wieder
zusammen streamen, ähm, was, was wollte ich jetzt noch sagen, empfiehlst du, warte mal
chat, ich wollte das, beste, bringst beste Möglichkeit, beste Möglichkeit eine SSD fest
zu halten, also wenn ihr was braucht, so irgendwie zum, zum schieren, bei, bei irgendwie bei
irgendeinem Sporteignis oder so, macht euch einfach so ein Ding einen Daumen und winkt
mit der, mit der, mit der, mit der Micro SD, so, also was wollte ich jetzt sagen, Moment
chat, ja, ganz aus dem Konzept gebracht, also, siehste, das hab ich, das hab ich ganz
vergessen, vielleicht wollte ich noch ein bisschen Deutschrap flamen, ich weiß es nicht,
ist auch egal, äh, aber zu der Frage von, von Gunny, Gunde, also, wie gesagt, C-Sharp
ist meine Lieblingsprogrammiersprache, das heißt nicht, dass das die beste Programmiersprache
für alles ist, der große Vorteil ist, wenn du C-Sharp lernst, dass du, warum ruckelt
denn das zwischendurch, was ist denn das hier, was, was soll das, Leute habt ihr das grad
gesehen, über, über, Übertragungs, der Übertragungs-Champ funktioniert nicht, WLAN-Champ ist am abkacken,
also, das schöne an C-Sharp ist, wenn du C-Sharp gelernt hast, du kannst damit mehr
oder weniger alles machen, was du machen willst, das ist halt nice, ne, du kannst von Surfer-Anwendungen
bis, äh, Web-Anwendungen bis ziemlich Low-Level-Geschichten, Audio-Video-Desktop-Krams, Mobile-Krams, wobei
Mobile-Krams wäre nicht unbedingt meine erste Wahl, kannst du mit C-Sharp alles machen,
das ist halt schön, und das finde ich gibt es so in dieser Form bei keiner anderen Sprache,
gerade die Möglichkeit für Windows-Desktop haben wir, also, für Windows-Desktop ist
es einfach das beste, was es gibt, Windows-Desktop ist ziemlich errotz, Windows-Desktop-Anwendungen
zu machen, aber wenn dann mit C-Sharp, Dogue-Coin ist die Zukunft, die habe ich auch schon gehört,
das ist kein Netzteil, das ist ein Switch da oben, das ist Manjaro mit i3-WM, das beste
zum C-Sharp-Lernen, ja, so paar Kurse sind nicht verkehrt, aber was ich, was ich empfehle
immer, wenn man einfach mal einen Einstieg sucht ist das hier, das da, das ist zwar,
das ist zwar Visual Studio, also Visual C-Sharp 2012, das ist nicht wirklich aktuell, aktuell
ist.NET Core 5, aber wenn du Kapitel 1 bis Kapitel, inklusive Kapitel 16 machst, den
Westen kannst du vergessen, das brauchst du nicht, dann hast du schon mal eine ganz gute
Übersicht über so die absoluten Basics und wir wissen ja alle, ich muss es nicht sagen
Leute, mit was man anfängt, das ist nicht verkehrt, ansonsten gibt es so viele Webcasts
und Tutorial-Videos und alles mögliche auf YouTube, da kommt man auch an Start mit und
Zweifelfall kann man sich auch irgendeinen Kurs kaufen, aber da kann ich dir nichts empfehlen,
hast du C-Sharp beim Physik gelernt, nein ich konnte das vorher schon, auf der Arbeit
musst du ABAP entwerfen, ernsthaft, es gibt Leute, die ernsthaft ABAP machen müssen?
Moment, oder war ABAP das SAP Zeug, war das dieses SAP, war das diese SAP Krämpel da?
Ne, mit Java kannst du zum Beispiel keine schönen Windows Desktop Anwendungen machen,
du kannst mit Java zwar Desktop Anwendungen oder generell GUI Anwendungen machen, aber
die sind so ein bisschen Java Style halt, aber Java kommt in die Richtung ja, wobei Java
weiß ich nicht, ob man iOS Apps mitmachen kann, na klar mit Elotrix zusammen, Warzone,
auf gehts Leute, ja das ist aus dem 3D Drucker das Logo, F-Sharp kenne ich ja, kenne ich
aber nicht gut aus, SAP, ok, wie findest du PowerShell, ziemlich gut, aber nicht als
interaktive Shell, für Automatisierung ist PowerShell cool, ne iOS ist nicht only Swift
und C-Sharp, das mag zwar die Native Geschichte sein, aber meiner Meinung nach die einfachste
Variante für Mobile Apps sind entweder Flutter oder sowas wie Ionic, einfach JavaScript quasi
Elektron für Mobile, dann hast du eine App für alles zusammen, mags wie lange muss man
programmieren lernen um damit Geld verdienen zu können, das kann man nicht in Zeit messen,
so aber, also bevor ich jetzt hier lange rumlaufe, ich kann jetzt ja gleich mit euch weiter labern,
ich flash mal die SSD, äh die MicroSD, warum sag ich immer SSD, und warum ist da eigentlich
immer dieses komische, dieses komische Adapter dabei, hier, dieser komische Adapter, wozu,
wo wenn, ich hab also von diesen Adaptern, ohne Scheiß Leute, hab ich bestimmt 40,
damit es nach mehr aussieht vielleicht, ok, jetzt geht immer noch richtig auf,
guckt euch das mal an, Aufreißchamp, komm mal, und das ist der eine, das ist alles,
alles das hier für so, für so viel Inhalt, ist natürlich, das ist natürlich gerechtfertigt,
ne, dafür, also klar, exellent, so dann flashen wir das jetzt erstmal, schenkt das den Leuten,
die du nicht magst zum Geburtstag, ich bevorzuge Leute, die ich nicht mag, zu ignorieren bzw.
gar nicht in Kontakt mitzudrehten und denen schon gar nichts zum Geburtstag zu schenken,
so wir flashen das mal nebenbei, also wie gesagt, wenn es noch was gibt Chat, schießt los,
dann kann ich jetzt noch beantworten, wir haben ja noch Zeit, während das flasht,
wenn ich die, wenn ich das rein bekomme, hallo, so schauen wir mal, wir hatten den Kram runtergeladen,
ich lasse es jetzt mal oben eingeplendet, ich find das eigentlich ganz nice, hallo Chat,
du kannst die Adapter auf der Gamescom raushauen, ja dann müsste ich auf die Gamescom gehen,
ich hab gehört, ich hab gehört, auf der Gamescom kopiert man sich Fastpasse,
fastpasses, nicht zu verwechseln mit DSL, fastpath, hat jemand eine gute, hat jemand eine gute,
so ein Organizer für Micro SDs, Samsung Pro Endurance, beste, Grüße an Isle of Cookies,
ja, ich hab mit ihm danach telefoniert und ich hab noch ein paar Sachen erfahren dazu,
die sag ich jetzt aber nicht im Stream, weil erstens könnten da manche Leute Ärger kriegen
und ich vielleicht auch, keine Ahnung, ich will da keinem auf die Füße treten,
wir haben danach telefoniert noch mal und was da wieder für Dinger gelaufen sind,
ich weiß schon warum ich mit dem ganzen YouTube Deutschland Crap nichts mehr zu tun hab,
ja gut aber den da, also mal ernsthaft Leute, also den Kicks da, den findet ihr nicht auf
Thingiverse, es sei denn irgendjemand hat meinen Kicks nachgebaut und auf Thingiverse gestellt,
der da ist MaxSource Exclusive, so wo haben wir denn jetzt uns das aktuelle Raspberry Pi,
ich hab es doch letztens erst runter geladen, Raspberry Pi OS Booster, da ist es, Booster,
ich mein, Leute wir machen was anderes, ich zeig euch mal was, wir flashen aktuell das
Ubuntu drauf, weil Ubuntu 64 Bit, da kann ich mehr Heat Generaten, VCG GAN, gibt's das unter Ubuntu?
Weil das wär wichtig, damit kann man nämlich die Temperatur auslesen vom Raspberry Pi,
da hat Windows, ja genau, ok ich glaub wir bleiben doch beim offiziellen Respian,
gibt's bei Ubuntu ok, weil hier sieht es nicht so aus als gibt's das,
ok wir probieren das jetzt einfach mal aus, ich zeig euch mal was cooles, wenn ihr Arch habt
oder Manjaro habt, da gibt's so nen Tool, den Raspberry Pi Imager, ist eigentlich viel praktischer
als mit Edger jedes mal den Kram zu machen, du kannst den Notexporter drauf schmeißen,
wenn der das ohne diesen Kram auslesen kann, ja dann kann ich das machen, und jetzt starten wir
das Ding, Raspberry Pi Imager und das ist viel angenehmer als den Kram jedes mal runterzuladen
und zu flashen, Choose OS sagen wir einfach anderes OS, nee anderes OS, Ubuntu und dann
nehmen wir 64bit, 20.10, ARM64, Bam, Choose SD Card, ich dachte eigentlich das hat er,
Choose SD, wie ernsthaft, das erkennt er nicht noch, oh Gott, MonkaS, 3-Hat-Programm alter,
what the fuck, alter doch, oi mate, oi, äh, er kennt ja,
er erkennt ja die SD-Karte grad nicht, ok Leute, großer Nintendo Trick,
PulseChamp, hallo,
warum erkennt der denn jetzt nichts, der erkennt die micro SD-Karte nicht, but why, was ist das,
ok jetzt ist die große preisfrage, wisst ihr was wir probieren, wir probieren jetzt diesen
kack Adapter aus, aber es damit erkennt, der krümelt 2 Monate, dankeschön, ich hab noch
irgendwo einen anderen SD-Karten-Leser, wartet mal, fuck den hab ich schon ewig nicht mehr
verwendet, weil ich nicht, weiß nicht wo der ist, ich hab irgendwo noch einen anderen
SD-Karten-Leser, liegt der hier oben vielleicht, nee, oi, ich hab den, ich hab ihn letztens
irgendwo gesehen, ist er hier, hm, hier ist er nicht, hm, wartet mal, ich guck mal kurz
hier neben, ob der hier neben liegt, SD-Karten-Champ, ist der Cam Link, aber kein SD-Karten-Leser,
na gut, ich mein der Kram wird schon funktionieren, so, ich machs jetzt mal raus, jetzt nehmen
wir mal diesen Müll hier und gucken ob wir das da irgendwie, hier muss man das da rein,
erst mal abputzen und schon drauf fingern, so, zack, probieren wir mal ob es so funktioniert,
ok Leute, ich reboote mal, ich mein prinzipiell erkennt er den Kram ja, was, USB-Disconnect,
war das jetzt nicht durchgereicht, warum erkennt er diese Karte da drin nicht, was ist das
schon wieder für ein Crap, ist die SD-Karte wirklich im Arsch, komm lass mal unter Windows
gucken, lass mal unter Windows gucken, ist das, wie, CacWaite, unter Windows erkennt
das, äh, jetzt bin ich aber ratlos, nee, nee am formatieren kann das nicht liegen,
der muss das ja erkennen als SD-Karte, what the hell, was ist denn das für eine kacke,
ok Leute, reboot, easy, nee die verschwindet ja unter Windows wenn man die unter Linux
mountet, wüsste ich jetzt wo mein anderer Micro SD-Karten-Reader ist, ne, dann könnte
ich den auch, könnte ichs mal ausprobieren, aber ich hab echt keinen Plan, wenn ich hier
so am Schreibtisch rumguck, sind zwar Geräte da, die sehr ähnlich aussehen, aber der Micro
SD-Karten-Leser ist nicht da, mal gucken ob es jetzt geht nach dem Reboot, Leute das
ist doch noch, hat doch mit Lateisystem überhaupt nichts zu tun, wenn er das Device nicht mal
findet, chat, CacWaite, wenn er noch nicht mal das Gerät an sich erkennt, dann ist es,
das ist noch ein Schritt vor Fallsystem, ha, da ist sie, easy, Reboot, einfach Leute, einfach
Rebooten, easy, alles gut, alles geregelt, einfach, einfach Rebooten, sehr schön, sehr
schön, ok Champ, so, jetzt können wir endlich das machen, was ich eigentlich machen will,
also OS auswählen, ist die Musik ein bisschen laut heute, ticken laut vielleicht, bisschen
leiser, so, Reboot-Champ, hatte ich irgendeine Kernel-Update gestern noch gemacht, ach was
doch immer, man weiß es nicht, aber, sag mal mal so, ne, auch mit Kernel-Update sollte
eigentlich ein USB, ist wurscht, so, zack, Ubuntu, 64bit, Server OS, jawoll, Choose SD-Kart,
da ist es, 64G, right, yes, so, man sieht die Dinger sind jetzt auch ein bisschen schneller,
die sind jetzt auch ein bisschen schneller als die andere SD-Karte, ja, der muss auch
nebenbei runterladen, welches Case, nein, dieses Case hier, da steht es ja schon drauf,
the most beautifully crafted Raspberry Pi 4 Case, und wenn der Hersteller das sagt, wissen
wir ja prinzipiell, dass das immer stimmt, hat uns jemals den Hersteller schon angelogen,
glaub nie vor, die Hersteller sagen aus Prinzip immer die Wahrheit, 16 times the detail, so,
jetzt kann ich mal ein bisschen Chat gucken, während das flasht, also, muss der das Image
bei jedem Start neu runterladen, ne, ich glaub der cached sich das irgendwo, wie sieht denn
das Case aus, so, passiv gekühlt, wir packen das gleich aus, aber erstmal muss ich den
Raspberry Pi flashen, so, ich scroll jetzt mal kurz den Chat durch, ob ich irgendwas
vergessen hab, zu beantworten, während der hier am flashen ist, also Chat, ich muss euch
sagen, ich verstehe euren Reflex, wenn was nicht geht, den Self dazu zu geben, dass, den
gleichen Reflex hab ich auch immer, wenn irgendwas nicht geht, aber es wäre schön,
wenn ihr manchmal ein bisschen langsamer werdet, weil manche Sachen ergeben keinen Sinn, zum
Beispiel, wenn man erst das Device nicht sieht, braucht man sich um das File System geile Gedanken
machen, aber trotzdem, Big Brain Chat, wie immer, Maxwort plus Champ, ja, Slow Champ,
has been written, ok, nice, continue, zack, und jetzt das allerwichtigste, was man sowohl
unter Ubuntu als auch unter Raspian machen muss, ja, 30 FPS vm ist eindeutig zu wenig,
viel, viel zu wenig, man muss den Kram mounten, ich hab's bestimmt noch in der History, mount,
sdb mounten, oder halt da, wo euer SD-Karte ist, touch ssh, weil ansonsten könnt ihr
euch nicht einloggen drauf, es suckt, so, gut, dann können wir die SD-Karte rausziehen,
zack, zack, und können jetzt das ganze mal in den Raspberry Pi stecken und gucken, ob
da alles startet, machen wir das hier mal weg, oh, da ist noch das alte drin, das leg ich
mal hier oben in so ein Fach, dass ich's wieder finde, zack, gut, mir fällt grad auf, ich
hab kein Netzwerkkabel, oder doch, oder hab ich die draußen alle im Schrank, wartet mal,
ich werd hier doch irgendwo, ohne dass ich jetzt rausgehen muss, noch Netzwerkkabel rumfliegen
haben, was ich nicht brauche, hm, ich hab aufgeräumt, manchmal hat es echt seine Nachteile,
wenn man aufräumt, wenn man aufräumt ist danach nix mehr da, weiß nicht, ob ihr dieses
Phänomen kennt, das ist wie, wenn man Unreal Tournament spielen will, da will man ja auch
nicht, dass es lädt, nee, ich hab kein Netzwerkkabel mehr hier, ich hab alles aufgeräumt, top,
Ordnungs-Champ, bin sofort wieder da, die neben mir, die neben mir, die neben mir, die
neben mir.
WLAN will ich in dem Fall jetzt erstmal nicht haben, so ich hab das längste Netzwerkkabel
aller Zeiten geholt, also ich glaub ein viel kürzeres Netzwerkkabel werdet ihr nicht finden,
Miniaturnetzwerkkabel, aber ich mein, für unsere Zwecke, wenn man das jetzt mal auseinander
kriegt irgendwie, für unsere Zwecke soll das hier ausreichen, zack, so, was darfs sein,
welcher Port, acht oder so, vier, vier, optimal Port, optimaler PogChamp-Port, so, Raspberry
Pi Netzteil ist hier, dann schließen wir das jetzt mal an, so ein bisschen, sodass man
das irgendwie gescheit sieht, so, und dann gucken wir mal, ob wir uns einloggen können,
so, da muss jetzt eh erstmal die Festplatte, äh, nicht die Festplatte, die Micro SD-Karte
muss der jetzt hier erstmal hier irgendwie, macht der was, ja, erstmal resizen und alles
mögliche, seht ihr eigentlich, seht ihr, wartet mal, seht ihr, dass der Link aktiv
ist, erkennt man das, ja, das sieht man, ne, vielleicht müsste ich den Switch noch ein
bisschen, wartet mal, vielleicht mach ich den Switch noch ein bisschen hoch, dass man
die Ports, die Ports besser erkennt, probieren wir mal aus, weil ich hab mir überlegt, das
Setup, so, ist eigentlich ziemlich praktisch, du hast hier den Switch, du hast hier neben
die Steckdosenleiste und hier kannst du alles machen drauf, und ich muss es nicht rumlaufen,
das steht jetzt direkt am Fenster, ich muss eigentlich gar nichts machen im Endeffekt,
das ist ganz, ganz nützlich, so, besser jetzt, erkennt man es jetzt besser, jetzt erkennt
man noch besser, dass der Link an ist, oder, er macht keinen großen Unterschied, so, exquisite,
so jetzt schauen wir mal, ob wir Verbindungen zum Raspberry Pi bekommen, machen wir das
mal ein bisschen klein, das ist, ne, das ist kein SFP Plus Modul, das ist ein Direct Attached
Kabel, du meinst das da, ne, hier, den da, das ist ein 7 Meter Direct Attached Kabel,
das geht hinter in den Server Raum, so, wait a minute, den Raspberry Pi nicht erkannt, doch
hier, kann das Ding aus 7 Millionen Megaflips, Paint's Champ, Paint's Champ Joke, also SSH,
Copy ID, Ubuntu, ich glaube Ubuntu ist der Standard Login, yes, Ubuntu, Ubuntu irgendwie
so war das Passwort glaube, oder was, Ubuntu Leer, oder was, Ubuntu Passwort, ach man musste
sich erstmal ein, das ist, das ist, ne, ne, das ist Lowprane, Ubuntu Tackling, man muss
sich erstmalig einloggen und ein neues Passwort vergeben und dann kann ich das Passwort deaktivieren,
richtig hängen geblieben, so und jetzt, und jetzt geht das, richtig, richtig, richtig
Lowprane, Moment, wo ist mein Ubuntu Emote, find's nicht, Lowprane Jubantu, ja, da sind
wir am Start, das ganze ist jetzt deutlich schneller mit dieser SD Karte, mit dieser
Mikro SD Karte als mit der anderen, wir hätten auch die, wir hätten auch die SSD nehmen
können, so und jetzt gucken wir erstmal wie warm das ganze wird und jetzt gucken wir mal
ob das stimmt, ob der Chat Recht hat, der Chat meinte nämlich, VC Gen ist auf Ubuntu
vorhanden, das war nur der Sound, wieso ist das feste IP Adressen vergeben an ein Raspberry
Pi per SSH, so kennste, ist das gar nicht, Raspberry Pi Config und gut ist, VC Gen ist
nicht drauf, Chat, wer hat mich jebaited, achso, na, aber VC Gen CMD ist auch nicht drauf,
ah man kann's aber nachinstallieren, ok nur halb jebaited, nur halb jebaited, ich will
aber kein Nodexporter da drauf jetzt installieren und danach irgendwie im Grafana einrichten
oder sonst was, ich will einfach die Temperatur auslesen, kann Sensors das eigentlich auch,
von Kryptowagen hab ich keine großartige Ahnung, ok VC Gen CMD und jetzt, ich hab keine Ahnung
wie die, Temperature, Measure Temp, ok, Measure Temp, exellent, also, CPU, CPU ist 48 Grad,
Stress Suspension, so und jetzt machen wir mal ein bisschen Temperatur auf dem Ding,
hallo Chat, das sieht voll, das sieht voll 3-Head aus, wenn ich winke und nur die halbe
Hand drinne ist, das sieht an als, als er auslässt, ich kann irgendwen anfallen oder
so, das sieht voll kaputt aus, hast du noch Passivkühler, nee das machen wir mit dem
aktuellen Gehäuse, das gerade, also aktuell hab ich gar nichts, ich hab, guckt hier, Massive
Brain Chat, hier, gar nichts drauf, absolut nackig, Xeroxin und Dankeschön für den Zap,
warum benutzt du T-Max, weil's besser ist, weil du da so Big Brain Sachen machen kannst
wie Splitten oder so und dann wieder, und dann wieder raus, reinzoomen und rauszoomen
und Zeug und du kannst relativ easy sharen, was bei Screen auch geht, aber nicht so einfach
ist, so, Watch, was war das, VC, Gen, CMD, Measure, Measurer Temp, so und wie sagt man
bei Watch noch mal die Zeit wie er aktualisieren soll, N, ah yes, so, Hardtop, gucken wir uns
mal an wie die Auslastung ist, so, ok, es war mal ein bisschen Temperatur, Stress, Minus
Minus CPU 8, nee, CPU 4, jetzt bin ich mir nicht sicher wie es weiter geht, also wir
machen Stress Leute, Temperatur geht rauf, 100% CPU Auslastung, hat der Raspberry Pi
irgendeine Art von, keine Ahnung, Hyper Threading oder sowas, lohnt sich das mehr als, lohnt
sich das mehr als 4 Threads zu starten, welches Case testen wir aktuell, es ist noch gar kein
Case dran, aber wir testen dieses hier, das ist meiner Meinung nach beste Case, sowohl
von der Verarbeitung her, als auch von der Optik, als auch, vielleicht nicht unbedingt
Nummer 1 bei der Kühlleistung aber ausreichend.
So, also es wird ordentlich warm, soll ich mal draufgreifen Leute, echt kann man das
direkt auslesen, aus Zyster ist das natürlich auch nice, oh, Alter, das ist heiss as fuck,
ob das nur 63 ist, ich weiß, au, das ist richtig heiss, die Argon Dinger sind richtig gut,
das stimmt, aber die sind größer und die sind, finde ich, fast schon ein bisschen zu
teuer.
Wisst ihr was wir jetzt noch bräuchten?
So eine Wärmebildkamera, die das erkennt, wie warm es ist, oder wir müssten uns einen
ESP32 machen mit einem Temperatursensor, mit so einem DS20, bla, wie auch immer, ich kann
einen Suspension machen, ja, und den dann da draufkleben, ok, das wird echt warm jetzt,
ok, mach ich, ich mach genau das Kommando, was du geschickt hast, wird ja nicht allzu
lange dauern, ah, siehste, Grip, geht schonmal nicht, Chat schickt Kommandos die nicht
funktionieren, muss man da 4 machen, 3 Headchats, hast du ihn übertakt, ne, das können wir
gleich noch machen, das können wir gleich noch machen, Suspension ist installiert, run,
ah, yes, exzellent, hier lassen wir mal kurz Suspension, es gibt glaube ich schon eine
Wasserkühlung, doch, ich glaube es gibt mittlerweile, es gibt mittlerweile eine Wasserkühlung, wir
brauchen mehr Subscriber, ja immer, ich weiß nicht ob ich euch schon erzählt habe, dass
wenn ihr einen Amazon Prime Account habt, dass ihr kostenlos einmal im Monat einen Streamer
eurer Wahl unterstützen könnt auf Twitch, so, hier hast du deine Ausgabe, deine Suspension
Ausgabe, exquisite, so und jetzt machen wir nochmal Stress und danach übertakten wir
ihn nochmal, ja, kann man machen, also selbst ausdrucken ist auch eine Variante, allerdings
aus dem 3D Drucker kriegst du ja keine wärmeleitenden Gehäuse raus, also keine Metall Gehäuse, wie
lange Stress, solange bis sich die Temperatur nicht mehr nennenswert verändert, also das
letzte Mal sind wir glaube ich hoch auf, frag mich nicht, 78 Grad oder so gekommen, mit
dem letzten Pi 4, bevor wir es ins Gehäuse gebaut haben, in ein anderes Gehäuse, nicht
in das Gehäuse, das Gehäuse hatten wir im Stream noch nicht, aber jetzt lassen wir
ihn erstmal ordentlich, ordentlich Temperatur, und dann übertakten wir ihn, ich weiß gar
nicht mehr wie das ging, ich glaube config.txt, Monster360 abonniert Twitch Prime, Dankeschön,
Massive Sub IQ++ Dankeschön für die Subscription, Sellout hat gewirkt, ab und zu muss man ein
bisschen Sellout machen, Pi Overclock, ich glaube man muss irgendwas in config.txt schreiben,
ich habe, das ist Ubuntu drauf, ich habe kein config, also ich habe kein config oder so
was, kann man das nachinstallieren, nee, übertakten jetzt, also hier, config, excellent, das ist
super, dass in der config übertakten geht, aber angeblich geht das hier, wie sieht man
die Clockspeed, das ist doch einfach nur, ach hier, Frequency, hier Frequency, Salken
21, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön für den Sub, so, Boot, config, nee warte mal, wo liegt
das Ding, Moment wo, config, CacWaite, die gibt es bei mir gar nicht, CacWaite, ok da
müssen wir mal suchen, Ubuntu Overclock Pi 4, tja Killcard, du musstest so schreiben,
dass ich sehe, jetzt habe ich es zufällig mal gesehen, aber wenn die Fragen nicht explizit
an mich gehen, dann sehe ich die nicht, ok wie übertaktet man da, man kann die Datei
vielleicht einfach anlegen, hast du aktuell schon einen neuen Job, wenn ja wo, wenn man
fragen darf, ich habe keinen neuen Job, ich habe immer noch den gleichen Job, Overvoltage,
BAM, ok Leute, wir übertakken jetzt, config.txt und einfach jetzt diesen Kram da rein, ok
wir übertakken jetzt von 1500 Mhz auf 2000 Mhz, ok schauen wir mal, mal gucken ob das
so funktioniert, und wir overvolten auch, Nexonos, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön für den
App, das YouTube Kündigungsvideo, ja ich weiß nicht, wie weit du es geguckt hast, aber
in dem YouTube Kündigungsvideo erzähle ich nicht von meinem aktuellen Job, sondern dort
wo ich meine Ausbildung gemacht habe, und am Ende erzähle ich auch, dass ich nach der
Ausbildung dort gelandet bin, wo ich jetzt bin, ok mal schauen, übertaken hat nicht funktioniert,
ok wait, ok vielleicht muss man Last verursachen, vielleicht muss man Last verursachen, dass
es funktioniert, Stress, Stress, Stress, Jawoll, BAM, nope, ich hab doch rebooted, geht nicht,
übertaken not, not possible, falsche Ordner, echt, ne oder, oh, Kirk Wade, Ups, äh, ok
use config, hast du im Tätigse user, OMG, Info freqemity, ok, ich reboot nochmal, es
aked
Kann man das auch irgendwie mit dem VC Gen Tool machen?
Die Musik ist übrigens laut auf einmal, ne?
Passt eigentlich.
So, mal gucken, was der jetzt sagt.
Oh, startet er jetzt nicht mehr oder was?
Ah, da ist er wieder.
MonkaS.
Dachte schon, er startet nicht mehr.
Das wär jetzt jetzt echt gewesen.
Bäm, 2 Gigahertz, jawoll, wow, 6000 Gigahertz, ne, ach ne, 600 Megahertz nur noch, alles
klar.
Okay, dann gucken wir doch mal, wie warm er jetzt wird.
Stress, bäm.
Ja, ja, alles ausgelastet.
Oh ja, da wird schon ein bisschen wärmer jetzt, he?
Wo ist ein Limit?
Wo, wo ist ein Limit?
Temperatur?
Leute, ah, zählt das als Selbstverletzung im Stream, wenn ich mich da jetzt verbrenne?
Werdest du dann gebannt?
Ah, Leute, das ist übelst heiß, das geht gut ab.
Okay, noch taktet er sich nicht runter, ähm, max Temperatur.
Ja, und?
Was, was, was, ab wann taktet er sich runter?
83 Grad.
Also, der takt, also anscheinend noch nicht.
Ah, über 85 Grad, okay, über 85 Grad taktet er sich runter.
Das Flirrcase, ich hab's auf Amazon bei einem Drittanbieter gekauft, ich kann jetzt aber
leider nicht genau sagen, für wie viel.
Guck mal, zeigt die Taktrate.
Ah, guck mal, jetzt vorbei, Leute, jetzt vorbei, jetzt wird's runtergetaktet.
86 Grad, jetzt vorbei, ich weiß gar nicht, ja, jetzt taktet er, taktet sich wieder hoch.
Guck, der taktet sich hoch und dann ab jetzt fängt er an, sich wieder runterzutakken.
Magfly, Dankeschön für den Sub, okay, ich würd sagen, das ist für Temperaturtest erst
mal genug oder wollen wir ihn noch ein Stückchen übertakken, wollen wir noch mal gucken, ob
noch ein bisschen mehr, wobei, wir sind jetzt schon am Limit, wir sind ja jetzt schon am
Limit, ja, wir sind jetzt schon komplett Temperature-Limit, okay, ich würd sagen, das ist warm genug,
nee, Ram-Over glaubt mir nicht, okay, der kommt ans Temperatur-Limit, dann würd ich
sagen, dann nehmen wir jetzt mal das Gehäuse und bauen das Ding ein und gucken wir mal,
guck mal, der taktet sich auch direkt runter dann, wenn er an 85 Grad kommt, siehst du
gleich, direkt, okay, boah, Alter, das ist heiß, aber da kannst du fast ein Ei drauf
machen, äh, so, dann schauen wir uns mal das Gehäuse an, würd ich sagen, ich switch mal
kurz rüber oder wisst ihr was, ich mach einfach Fullscreen, viel besser, ei, der Chat hat
da schon wieder komische, komische Ideen, also, dann packen wir das doch mal aus und
gucken uns das an, ob das wirklich das Most Beautiful Crafted Raspberry Pi Case ist, überhaupt,
schauen wir mal, so, wie geht denn das hier raus, so, okay, schon mal ganz nice verpackt,
wollen wir mal rein, so, was haben wir denn hier, was haben wir denn hier, haben wir das
Case drin und ansonsten nix, okay, das kann ich schon alles mal runterhauen, schmeiß
ich mal alles hier auf die Erd, das brauchen wir nicht, hier ist das Case drin, da ist es,
sieht recht unspektakulär aus, wir haben paar Schrauben, paar Schrauben, äh, ich denk
mal, das ist der Boden, vermute ich mal, und das ist das Teil, das Ding ist wirklich relativ
massiv, ja, weiß ich, ob man das, ob man das gut, gut hört, pass mal auf, also da ist
schon ein bisschen, bisschen Metall, also, na, das, das ist schon recht massiv, das Ding
und das kommt auf die, auf die, äh, CPU, by the way, aus welchem Grund hat denn das
ein Loch hier drinnen, sollte das nicht besser planaufliegen und nicht hier ein Loch haben,
wisst ihr was richtig pro wär, wisst ihr was richtig pro wär, hätt ich jetzt noch
Wärmeleitpaste, hätt ich hier noch irgendwo Wärmeleitpaste, das wär mal massiv exquisite,
oder, das ist kein Pet, oder ist da ein Pet dabei, wartet mal, ah hier ist ein Pet dabei,
guck mal, aber ich glaub Wärmeleitpaste wär cooler, oder, ich hab aber, glaub, also ich
hab definitiv noch, aber ich hab ja, wie gesagt, ich hab ja aufgeräumt, ähm, ich,
Leute, ich kriech mal kurz hier runter, da liegt nämlich noch ne Ikea-Tasche mit ganz
viel Kabeln drinnen, wo ich so die Überbleibsel, die muss ich noch wegräumen, wo ich noch
so die Überbleibsel drin hab, vielleicht hab ich Glück, und da ist noch ein bisschen
Wärmeleitpaste drin, weil das sind, das sind ganz viel alte Sachen drin, da könnte durchaus
noch ein bisschen irgendwo Wärmeleitpaste, die gute der Bauer, der Bauer Wärmeleitpaste
ist das, die ich da hier am Start hatte, irgendwie, Thermal Crissly Conduct, nee, nicht Conduct,
Conductornaut ist das Flüssigmetall gewesen, äh, Cryo Cryonaut, oder so hieß das Ding,
nope, nix dabei, schauen wir mal hier, ich krieg gerade ein bisschen auf die Erde rum,
ne, ah, ah, was denn hier, Noctua, Noctua Lüfter, Pogchamp, Pogchamp, nein, beim Noctua
Lüfter wär die Chance gut gewesen, dass es da irgendwo dabei wär, aber, nee, keine
Ikea Tasche hat keine Wärmeleitpaste für uns Leute, keine Wärmeleitpaste, zwar, ist
das hier, was ist das hier, ah, in your face, die gute Noctua Wärmeleitpaste ist es sogar,
ich hab zwar irgendwie noch die Thermal Crissly gehabt, aber die tut's auch, oder, das ist
nicht Pogch, da ich noch was auf die Stelle, bisschen Wärmeleitpaste gefunden hab, guckt
euch das mal an hier, und zwar ist das Noctua NT H1, ok, wir können, wir können das jetzt
ja mal, deswegen sind Noctua Lüfter auch so teuer, hat das einen erkennbaren Unterschied,
Leute wir können das erstmal probieren mit dem Pad und dann mit der, was mein Mikrofon
knattert, Saft, was knattert da, Jebait, ich hab ihn auf der Erde, ich bin eben auf
der Erde rumgekrabbelt, da kann's durchaus sein, dass es knattert, achso, jaja, ich
hab, bin eben auf der Erde rumgekrochen, ich würd erstmal Paste machen, sonst brauchst
du ein neues Pad, stimmt, ja, ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das einen erkennbaren Unterschied
hat, das könnte natürlich sein, Paste geht nicht wegen dem Abstand, oh nee, ernsthaft,
geht das, ah, fuck oder, wartet mal, jaja, wir machen mal kurz ab, äh, Leute, ich schalte
den Raspberry Pi mal aus, kurz, hat ja keinen Sinn, wir müssen ja nicht am lebenden Patient
rumdoktern, achso, ja, warum geht das wohl nicht, wenn ich grad das Netzwerkkabel rausgezogen
hab, keck wait, ah nee, okay, geht wieder, alles klar, hat sich erholt, ich mach mal aus,
wir können Paste, Pad, Paste machen, oh ja, für noch bessere Bindung, moin, was machst
du mit dem Pi, ich teste das, ob das Gehäuse taugt, ich hoffe mal, weil optisch und so
von der, von der Quality fühlt sich das ja bisher am besten an von allen Cases, die ich
so in der Hand hatte, also für den Pi, okay, ähm, jetzt probieren wir das mal aus, also
wenn ich den Kram hier draufsetze, machen wir mal ab, hier machen wir auch ab, oh das
Ding, ey, der ganze Raspberry Pi ist ultra heiß hier, nach der Burn-In Session da, so,
das muss ja nämlich hier so rein, so, und die Sache, ups, mach ich das überhaupt richtig,
so viel verkehrt kann man da ja eigentlich nicht machen, hier, so, oder doch, kann man
da was verkehrt machen, keck, keck, wait, keck, keck, keck, wait, warum, wait, wait a minute,
warum geht das nicht, äh, einfach mal drücken, ne, okay, oh Leute, Big Brain Finger Fertigkeit
sind jetzt gefragt, oh please, Kamera Kurs, stimmt ja, das sollte ich vielleicht machen,
äh, Big Brain Finger Fertigkeit ist gefragt, wie kriegt man es richtig rein, ich würde
sagen, man muss einfach ein bisschen, einfach ein bisschen drücken, ich mein, ah, guck
mal hier, hier raste, hier raste das dann ein, man kann das glaub einfach runterdrücken,
ha, zack, easy, wow, ist drin, das Problem ist jetzt, ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das auffliegt
oder nicht, man sieht es ja nicht, also, also, komm, Leute, wir nehmen das Pad, wir nehmen
das Pad, scheiß auf, scheiß auf, scheiß auf Wärmelite, passt auf, wenn wir die nice
Noctur Wärmelite passt haben, wir sehen nicht, ob das auffliegt und solange wir nicht sehen,
ob das auffliegt, dann hat es keinen Sinn, mach doch dünn Paste und teste, hmmm, dünn
Paste und testen, wo mach ich denn die Paste am besten drauf, äh, wahrscheinlich am besten,
am besten hier, äh, wie funzt denn das überhaupt, muss man das drehen, ah ja, so, ha, macht
das jetzt was, so, äh, ich bräuchte, ich bräuchte noch irgendeinen Spachtel oder sowas,
ich bräuchte noch irgendwie so einen Spachtel oder sowas, um das zu verteilen, vielleicht,
vielleicht beim Noctur auch sowas dabei gewesen, Noctur Spachtel, nee, kein Noctur Spachtel,
aber sowas hier, ähm, exquisite, so, jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das ganze Kontakt hat,
schauen wir mal, ich müsste ja, wenn es Kontakt hat, müsste ich es ja sehen, auf der CPU,
was meint ihr, meint ihr das tut, meint ihr das geht, so, jetzt sollte, jetzt sollte ich
eigentlich einen Fleck auf der CPU haben, wenn es richtig drauf ist, nope, nope, zu
großer Abstand, ok Leute, äh, ich brauch mal ein Stück Klopapier, ich bin gleich wieder
da, oder hab ich, hab ich hier irgendwie, ach komm hier, nimm mal das, geht auch, das
von der Verpackung, das geht genauso, exquisite Wärmeleitpaste verschmieren, so muss das sein,
jawoll, brauch ich mal eigentlich was ordentlich zum reinigen, ok, sauber genug, zack, mach
mal das Pad drauf, ja, keine Küchenrolle da, keine Küchenrolle, dass wenn ich irgendwas
umschmeiß, hab ich echt ein Problem, gut, dann machen wir dieses komische Pad drauf,
ui, Tütenöffner, jetzt rechtssicht wieder, dass ich absolut keine Fingernägel hab, so,
ok, also, ich würd sagen, wir pappen das, wir pappen das auf den, auf die CPU drauf,
das ist besser, weil dann ist es auf jeden Fall zentriert, weil das Ding hier ist größer,
oh, jetzt bräuchte man ein paar Grills mit Fingernägel, so, exzellent, muss noch den
Rahmen da oben abmachen, ok, wunderbar, rein damit, kenne ihn, Simona, danke für den Zap,
jetzt gehts net, doch jetzt, ey, what the, what the fuck, ich hatte so eben schonmal drin,
was ist das für Three-Head-Scheiß, Three-Head of Doom ist das hier, oh, das geht noch mal
rein, what the hell, wa, wa, wa, wa, warum, das ging doch eben schonmal, ich hatte so eben
schonmal drin, what the fuck, das ging doch eben easy as fuck rein, guck mal eben, eben
hatte ich einfach so, ah ok, bisschen Gewalt braucht man an der Stelle einfach, sieht so
aus, so und jetzt sollte das ein Strauf pappen, gut, dann machen wir jetzt noch den Schraubchamp
rein, passt das hier überhaupt, ja, passt, Moment, den Schraubchamp macht man hier unten
durch, was ist das jetzt, so, so für die SSD, würde sagen, ich würde sagen, das muss so
drauf und die SSD, und die SSD muss da so durch, die SSD mal raus, so, also ich würde
sagen, so, so gehörts, anders gehts ja auch nicht, das schwarze ist Plastik, ja, anders
gehts ja auch nicht, hier passt die SSD noch rein, Moment, ist falsch rum, ne, so rum
ist glaube ich richtig, na jetzt guck mal, die haben extra schönes Loch hier für die,
für die Micro SD drinnen, hier neben ist eine Aussparung, das ist wahrscheinlich für
die LEDs, das man sieht, wenn die LEDs angehen, so, also schreiben wir das mal, ja ich sag
immer SSD, obwohl es eigentlich eine Micro SD ist, frag mich nicht warum, irgendwie tue
ich mir schwer, in meinem Boomer-Hirn, Micro SD und SSD im Eifer des Gefechts auseinander
zu halten, Micro, Micro SSD, noch besser oder, Nano SSHD, ja das ist auch nicht schlecht,
Schraube, Schraube, Schraube, exellent, so, gut, alles fest, sitzt, passt, fühlt sich
auch recht hochwertig stabil an, sitzt auch ziemlich gut was die Slots angeht, sehr ordentlich,
hier seht ihr das, hier hat das Gehäuse eine Delle oder so ein Loch, das ist nicht so gut,
ich frag mich ja ob die mal einen Raspberry Pi bauen, der defaultmäßig auch über PoE
geht, das wäre cool, so, wenn die das richtig gemacht haben, sollte man jetzt eigentlich
hier die, hier die, die, die LEDs sehen, guck mal mal, ja guck mal man sieht, man sieht,
ich weiß nicht ob ihr es seht, seht ihr das, ja ne, ja, exellent, gut jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt wie warm das jetzt wird, schauen wir mal, ja man kann mit so einem Adapter
das machen, der dann von PoE auf den Strom geht vom Raspberry und so, das habe ich schon
gesehen, aber einfach PoE anstöpseln und geht, geht soweit ich weiß bei keinem Raspberry
Pi, LED Champ, gut, also, Clock, Temp, Stress, jetzt, jetzt schauen wir mal, ok Auslastung
ist wieder volle Pulle, so, mal gucken wie es jetzt hoch geht, was heißt PoE, PoE ist
Strom übers, hier Strom übers Netzwerkkabel, was, YEP ist auch weg, YEP hatten wir nie
aktiviert, jebaited, wir hatten Salami aktiviert, aber Salami war ja zu obszön, ok Gehäuse
wird ein bisschen warm, Gehäuse wird ein bisschen warm, aber Leute es bleibt ja mal
deutlich kühler, guckt mal, bei dem anderen war man mehr oder weniger instant, am Limit,
85 Grad, ne der kann das nur wenn du das passende PoE Head hast, der Raspberry Pi, da brauchst
du so ein extra Board für PoE und dann geht das mit dem Raspberry Pi 3B+, aber einfach
so out of the box geht das nicht, so also Temperatur ist absolut in Ordnung, Gehäuse
wird recht, ist lauwarm überall jetzt, aber passt schon, passt, ist ok, ja ist in Ordnung,
Doktor Max kontrolliert Temperatur, gut, ich würd sagen wir müssen jetzt noch mal ein
bisschen weiter übertakken oder, weil ich mein einfach nur bei 60 Grad bleiben, das
kanns ja jetzt nicht sein, welches Case ist das genau das da, Flirck Case, Flirck Case
und aktuell gibt es das sogar hier schon für 21,90, was ich finde ein recht guter Preis
ist, ok es ist weder das noch Chat at Price Champ, ich wollt eigentlich gucken was der
Versand kostet aber ich glaub der Versand ist mit Prime in dem Fall auch kostenlos, kostenlose
Lieferung ja, wie groß ist der Rahmen, der hat 4G, 4G, äh Moment, falsches Fenster,
fast, fast, ja 4G, das Armor Case, ja es gibt ein paar gute das kenn ich doch nicht,
das Argon Case ist auch ziemlich gut, ja das ist so ein ganz günstiges, das Argon Case
ist gut ist mir aber ein bisschen zu teuer, das für 11 Euro, na ich kauf mir jetzt nicht
jedes Raspberry Pi Case zum ausprobieren, es gibt ja auch jetzt die Argon Cases mit NVMe
und sowas drin, weißt du was passiert ist, was sagt der Umut denn, ähm, die IHK hatte
meinen Projektantrag nicht bekommen, obwohl ich den hochgeladen hatte, hab zum Glück
den Antrag runtergeladen gehabt und das gemerkt, ja sei froh, ist ja fast ähnlich wie bei
mir gewesen, die sind bei der IHK, die sind einfach echt extrem unfähig, ok also Leute
ich würd sagen Temperatur ist ok, ok also was ist denn so das, was ist denn so das Maximum
was denn das Ding verträgt, Arm Frequence Pi 4, mal gucken was ist da, Results, da gibt
es auch bestimmt Leute die Tests gemacht haben, Take it to the Max, exellent, Tom's Hardware
ein Google Eintrag weiter, das Tom's Hardware überhaupt noch gibt, ok 200, ja wie, die
haben ja nur 2 getestet, was hat der hier Maximum, ach mehr, mehr geht nicht oder was,
ach mehr geht nicht, ok also was, Overvoltage 6 und das, ok komm wir machen jetzt volle
Pulle, scheiß drauf, easy, Bam, Reboot, ich war mehr als nicht starten, kann er ja nicht
und ich glaube im Zweifelsfall, da hackt er sich halt runter oder, mal gucken, woop, woop
es lebt, lebt, lebt er noch, Patient scheint noch zu leben, Postchamp, Postchamp, mal warten
bis der Login geht, da ist er, da ist er Leute, 2147, Temp, Tres, Bam, Tres, Tres, Tres, Tres,
ok, jetzt geht die Temperatur doch ganz gut hoch, die Frage ist halt, die man sich stellen
muss, ne, macht man auf diesem Ding ernsthaft irgendwas großartig CPU limitiertes, wo man
das braucht, ich mein keiner, keiner transcoded Videos auf dem Raspberry Pi, ich mein es geht,
das ist das wichtigste, ja, Minecraft, ok, ohne Scheiß für einen Minecraft Server lasse
ich mir das gefallen, ja, ich mein Minecraft ist ja zumindest in der Java Edition schon
mal, da bekommt jedes mega Herz und bestimmt mit der C++ Edition auch, wie benutzt du die
Search Funktion in der History, Steuerung R und by the way Steuerung R sucht, also ihr
könnt ja sagen, das hier Steuerung R, dann gebt ihr den ersten Dings ein und wenn ihr
weiter Steuerung R drückt, dann springt er immer zu den nächsten Vorkommnissen und wenn
ihr Steuerung Shift R drückt, dann springt er zurück und das ist die wichtigste Funktion,
die ihr jemals in eurer Shell braucht, weil wer eine lange Shell History hat, der braucht
keine Server zu dokumentieren, einfach Shell nachgucken, meine History auf der Arbeit ist
glaube ich mittlerweile über 100.000 Zeilen lang und die wird auch immer, die wird auch
immer schön kopiert von einer Installation zur nächsten, das ist Standard Bash hier,
das was für ein Raspberry kommt, das hier bei mir ist ZSH, die hier, hier, hier, Leute,
wir sind volle Pulle übertaktet, genau, ihr müsst richtig das was Phipps schreibt, die
HIST Size müsst ihr anpassen und HIST File Size, sonst gehts nicht. Sollen wir mal gucken
wie warm es ist, oh ja, oh ja Leute, das Gehäuse, es ist unangenehm anzugreifen, definitiv,
es tut schon leicht weh am Finger, wenn man das zu lang drauf lässt auf dem Gehäuse,
kennst du Swiffing Bridge, klar wir haben schon ein paar Videos sogar hier zusammengeguckt,
also Maximum übertaktet und passiv gekühlt, schafft das Gehäuse aber auch gerade so,
das Ding unterunter takten zu halten und ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn es ein bisschen
wärmer ist im Sommer, so dass die Raumtemperatur ein bisschen wärmer ist und wenn es jetzt
noch 2-3 Stunden läuft und da vorlässt, glaube ich kommen wir auch ans Temperaturlimit in
dem Gehäuse, ey das ist echt warm das Ding, ne, also wenn ihr kalte Füße habt nachts
im Bett, legt das Ding unter die Decke oder erfreut eure Frau Freundin wie auch immer
mit, sagt ihr, kommt mal hier, ich hab Fußwärmer am Start, habt ja auch gleich ne Ausrede warum
Raspberry Pi ins Bett muss, da fehlt RGB, da fehlt RGB, ich hab noch ein paar Neopixel,
ich hab noch ein paar Neopixel, wir könnten RGB aufrüsten, ey das wird echt warm, ich
weiß aber grad nicht genau wo ich die Neopixel hab, ich hatte sie beim Aufräumen, ich hab
halt 50 mal gesagt, dass ich aufgeräumt habe und jedes Mal wo ich die Dinger aufgeräumt
hab, wusste ich vorher wo sie sind, jetzt nachdem ich aufgeräumt hab, weiß ich nicht
mehr wo die Dinger sind, wo könnte ich die Neopixel hin haben, Ikea Tasche, ne in der
Ikea Tasche ist das alte Zeug, wo ich nicht wusste wohin damit, vielleicht Leute, vielleicht
haben wir Glück, wir gucken mal in die Magic Box, in die Magic Microcontroller Box, ob
da irgendwo die Neopixels drin sind, wenn die Neopixels drin sind, dann können wir noch
RGB Beleuchtung machen, Magic Microcontroller Box, seht ihr irgendwo Neopixels, ok ich geb
zu, man erkennt jetzt nicht wirklich was, also Rüttelsensor, wir machen jetzt mal exquisite
Box Show, Rüttelsensor, nein, Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor, nein, ich hab keine Ahnung was es ist, nen
Wifi Modul, auch nicht, Relays auch nicht, Bewegungssensor, Relay auch nicht, ESP32,
Linksgedöns auch nicht, irgendwelche Stromdinger, mehr Relays, keine Ahnung, wo sind die Neopixels,
sind da irgendwo Neopixels drin, sieht nicht so aus, keine Neopixels Leute, sagt mir wenn
irgendwo Neopixels, ihr wisst ja gar nicht was ihr gucken müsst, aber guck mal, einfach
random noch ne Raspberry Pi Zero drin, Lullwee, Rüttelsensor, alles keine Neopixels Leute,
ne, sieht nicht so RGB, RGBig aus gerade, ok wo könnten die Dinger noch sein, Magic
Microcontroller Box wieder zumachen, keine Neopixels drin gewesen, Arts Delivery, ja beste,
Arts Delivery, Eats, die haben echt ne richtige Chance verschenkt sich Eats Delivery zu nennen,
ein Eats Delivery wäre nun mal wirklich mit Abstand der beste Name von nem Lieferdienst
überhaupt, wo könnt ich die Neopixels haben, ich geh mal draußen an den Schrank gucken,
mal ganz schnell, in der Zwischenzeit guck mal wie warm das ist, oh Leute, es schmilzt
gleich.
Ok.
ne leute, leute ich muss euch enttäuschen, ich find die neopixels jetzt auf die schnelle
nicht, das sind so einzelne leds, ich hab sogar so ein paar leds die man direkt per
usb anschließen kann und dann plinken lassen kann, ich hab mir gedacht wir machen jetzt
den spaß und machen eine runde rgb beleuchtung noch, ich guck noch mal schnell in die anderen
kartons ob da irgendwas drin ist, was ich ja zurecht mache, gar nix, raspberry pi 4 ins
gehäuse eingebaut und jetzt mal gucken wie warm er wird, aber leute wir sind gleich am
temperaturlimit, wir sind auch temperaturlimit erreicht, gleich taktet er sich runter, monka
auf a clock
Keine Chance Leute, ich hab jetzt mal noch 2 Kisten durchwühlt, keine RGB Beleuchtung
am Start, Fields RGB Man, Fields RGB Man, wüsste ich nur wo ich den Kram hingemacht
hab, ich hatte nämlich noch so ein paar Plink Dinger, die konntest du einfach in USB stecken
und dann, oh das Gehäuse, Alter, ok, also jetzt kann man den Finger nicht mehr drauflassen,
das ist zu heiß, ohne Scheiß, du kannst nicht mehr angreifen, da verbrennt du dich auf Dauer
wenn du nicht den Finger lang dran, au, ne, keine gute Idee, deaktiviert das nicht automatisch
das Downclocking, kein Plassen Schimmer, aber taktet sich nicht runter, oder, oben am Plastik,
hm, geht so, Plastik ist, Plastik ist ok, Hot Case, ja, richtig, richtig Verbrenn Case
angesagt, also nicht, das ist auf jeden Fall deutlich zu heiß, aber das Gehäuse schafft's,
ja, kann sich nicht beschweren, Maximum übertaktet, das Gehäuse schafft's gerade so, aber wirklich
kommt ganz am Rande, das zu halten, doch top kann man sich nicht beschweren, Poggers, Alter,
oder, doch, Massive Pog, je nachdem wie man's, wie man's sieht, ja, das Ganze verbraucht
übrigens gerade, ich weiß nicht ob ihr's seht, kennt man das, das Ganze braucht gerade,
9,2 Watt, also mehr kannst du mit dem Raspberry Pi 3 anscheinend nicht verbrauchen, du kannst
auch ein bisschen IO machen, aber so bei 9,62 wie auch immer ist Schluss, das Ding hat 4
Kerne, ja, genau, Hochkant aufstellen, jetzt kommen die Big Brain, Leute, das waren jetzt
Hochkant aufstellen, wir stellen jetzt Hochkant auf, mal gucken ob er dann kälter wird, der
bleibt nicht stehen, Hochkant, Crap Netzwerk Kabel, Alter, bleibst du stehen, kein Q-Switch,
bleibt nicht stehen, vielleicht so, keine Chance, so hier, so, perfekt, Diagonal aufstellen,
ja, kommt mal, jetzt hat er kaum Kontakt mit dem Boden, weiß jetzt nicht ob das gut oder
schlecht ist, aber das macht keinen Unterschied, Leute, ja gut, wenn du draufpustest, Leute,
wenn man draufpustet wird es natürlich kühler, das ist klar, wenn du draufpustest wird es
natürlich kühler, das kann ich euch, da hole ich mal was, da kann ich euch was zeigen,
das ist ein Kabel, da kann ich euch was zeigen, das ist ein Kabel, da kann ich euch was zeigen,
da kann ich euch was zeigen, das ist ein Kabel, da kann ich euch was zeigen, das ist ein Kabel,
Kühlchamp ist am Start
Der Kühlchamp
Wo stellt man das jetzt am besten hin so dass es am maximalsten vorbeigeht
Der Kühlchamp so
Achtung Kühlchamp activated
Ja
Leute der Kühlchamp ist kaputt oder
Ah ne der hat nen Knopf hinten lull
Kühlchamp ist an
Boah pass mal auf jetzt geht die Temp runter wie nix. Guck mal hier jetzt geht die Temp runter wie nix. Äh, Keg-Waite
Ke- Was ist das?
Was ist das?
Ich glaube ich ich glaube das das ist nicht das ist nicht richtig gelagert davor
Wollte man das Ding nicht irgendwie drehen doch guck mal
Jetzt hier jetzt der Pus-Champ ist am oh oh ich hab Wärmel- oh fuck ich hab Wärmel halt passt da unten dran hängen
Äh Saurei
Abmachen
Naja gut so was macht die Temp? 80 Grad 76 hier
Der Pus-Champ kühlt ordentlich
Wir müssen das ich muss das so machen irgendwie das muss mehr an das Gehäuse dran
Jetzt
Aber ne so ist schon okay
Der Pus-Champ guckt euch das mal an
Also man sieht aktiv Kühlung bringt bringt was ja
Gleich wie kühler das Gehäuse
Guckt mal jetzt könnt ihr den Raspberry Pi nicht nur als Fußwärmer verwenden sondern auch als Heizungsersatz
Nee ich hänge das Ding jetzt nicht aus dem Fenster
An Minus-Demperatur also ich muss das Fenster auf meinem Raspberry Pi raushängen
Guck mal 69 Grad jetzt kann man das jetzt kann man das tatsächlich nicht nur als Fußwärmer sondern echt als als Heizung verwenden
Nee nicht wirklich also wenn ihr damit was heizen wollt dauert ein bisschen
Aber aber theoretisch funktioniert das
Ja
Ich meine wer hat sonst schon einen 9 Watt Heizlüfter die haben sonst immer 2000
Da freuen sich die die die Öko Leute auch
Am einfach Energie gespart
Wir brauchen einen 2 KW Heizlüfter wenn du auch einen 9 Watt Raspberry Pi Heizlüfter haben kannst
Kannst du damit ein Raspberry Pi backen? Oh Pains-Champ, der war schlecht
Den Ventilator musst du da zurechnen ja ok der dann runter ne Runde mal auf keine Ahnung 11 12 mein in wegen uns hochkommt auf aber mehr nicht
Macht im Vergleich zu 2000 immer noch kein Unterschied ich meine er heizt nicht im Vergleich zu 2000 heizt er halt mal gar nicht aber aber er heizt theoretisch darauf kommt es aber nicht
Ich meine er heizt nicht im Vergleich zu 2000 heizt er halt mal gar nicht aber aber er heizt theoretisch darauf kommt es an
Theoretische theoretische Heizleistung ist huge
Nee auch nicht
Und man kann einen Minecraft Server drauf laufen lassen ich meine überlegt euch mal was du da was du da der Umwelt alles Gutes tun kannst
Du kannst Minecraft hausten und die Wohnung heizen und das alles mit 50 Euro Einsatz
Das ist A++++ Energie Klasse
Und stellt euch das ganze jetzt noch mal stellt euch hier die Kiste jetzt mit RGB vor stellt euch vor wir hätten hier einen Stick dran der irgendwie richtig schön RGB mäßig mäßig leuchtet
Ja sag euch das wäre hier exquisite
Mit RGB wird das ganze noch mal um 2 Faktor 2 geboostet werden
Ja mit RGB konnten wir auch locker auf 3 Gigahertz übertacken
Safe Safe Call
Gar kein Problem
Das Gehäuse sieht ein bisschen dreckig aus oben jetzt ne als ich das da eingerieben hab
Vielleicht soll ich das mal echt sauber machen
Ich hab halt nur nix da ich hab nur dieses komische
Papier hier da was ehrlich gesagt nicht sauber macht
Tja Leute da haben wir es aber das Gehäuse ist wirklich poggers
Also jetzt mal ganz ohne Spaß viel dummes Zeug gelabert die letzte Viertelstunde aber das Gehäuse ist wirklich nice
Das sieht nicht nur gut aus das hat alle notwendigen Funktionen du hast sogar ne Anzeige was die LEDs macht was die LEDs machen
Kommst an alles dran inklusive SD Karte, Mikro USB, Audio es gibt ja übrigens Geräte die noch ne Audio Ausgang haben so ein Klinkenstecker
Kommst hier hinten an alles dran und das Gehäuse bleibt schön schön kühl wenn man das nicht Maximum übertaktet und volle Pulle 4 Kerne laufen lässt
Stimmt das sind Mikro HDMI wie komm ich auf Mikro USB?
An den Kamera Anschluss kommst du tatsächlich nicht dran wobei du da auch deine Probleme hast wie kriegst du das Kamerakabel raus
Das würde wahrscheinlich hier neben funktionieren guck mal hier neben hast du ne Öffnung drin im Gehäuse
Du müsstest das Kamerakabel durchmachen ja das wird funktionieren das kannst du ja anschließen und dann hier neben raus machen ja das wird gehen
So mal machen den Pustchamp mal wieder aus
Aus ärgert mich dass ich die RGB Dinger nicht finde
Ne echt keine Ahnung wo die RGB USB Dinger sind
Na gut was das ist auf Slot 0 das kann ich dir zeigen das da
Gibt es für den Pi 4 schon ne zukünftige Aufgabe? Ja der ist rein für den Stream da
Ich hab den mir extra neu gekauft weil den letzten Raspberry Pi den ich für den Stream hatte
Der wurde zu meinem neuen Unify Access Point äh nicht Access Point Unify Controller
Da hab ich den alten Raspberry Pi 3 abgelöst der ist nur für den Stream sonst nix
Wenn wir irgendwann die Sachen ausprobieren
Also hier ist kein Problem ich kanns mal ausprobieren ich hab hier irgendwo nen
Ich hab hier doch in der Ikea Tasche eben nen, wartet mal nen HDMI gesehen
Hier guckt mal kann ich euch zeigen
Hier guckt mal HDMI
HDMI
Gar kein Problem Funst passt wunderbar
Alles gut
Perfekt
Exzellent sozusagen exquisite
So wir machen jetzt mal die Big Brain Noctua Wärmeladpaste wieder zu
Bevor es noch mehr kleckert das Ding
Zu und wieder hier rein
Braucht man bestimmt nochmal
Dieses komische eingesiffte Ding kommt da auch rein
Was immer das ist
Reflink für das Case
Nee hab ich nicht
Klick einfach in den Reflink von mir an und kaufs dann
Das zählt für alles was man kauft
Wenn nicht dann nicht
Ja Leute so siehts aus
Mehr Content hab ich für heut net geplant
Hab ich irgendwas übersehen im Chat
Hab ich irgendwas im Chat übersehen zeig mal her
Cute Chat
Du hast jetzt nen 3D Drucker gekauft
Exzellent
Hab ich an Weihnachten
Achso Tutorial ganz bestimmt
Hatten wir schon, hatten wir schon
Hatten wir auch schon
Dinger heißen offiziell Rüttelsensor
Ich glaub großartig Erdbeben erkennen
Keine Ahnung ob das so gut damit funktioniert
Ja doch wahrscheinlich auch
Zeit für VU
Wir können mal gucken ob ein Server
Ja aber ins Bett wird doch gehen oder
Das sieht da mega hässlich aus
Das kann man doch heute wahrscheinlich schon ziemlich easy machen oder
Wow
Achso weil es die GPR ausdurchleitet
Ok
Das hatten wir eigentlich alles schon
Ich hab nix übersehen oder
Nix übersehen
Nö
Ja wie gesagt für 20 Euro kriegst du ja schon das komplette Case was ich da gezeigt hab
Also für 20 Euro kriegst du ja schon ungefähr
Für 21 Euro kriegst du ja schon das komplette
Das komplette Case
Also ich weiß nicht wie sinnvoll das ist da
Nur nen Lüfter zu kaufen
Na gut wenn man Lüfter haben will
Und an die GPI auskommen will
Ist das tatsächlich nicht schlecht
Weil an die GPI aus kommst du hier nicht
GPI outchamp ist hier nicht
Das Agon Neo
Ja das kann man sich auch kaufen das ist hier nicht schlecht
Die Agon Cases sind eigentlich auch ganz gut immer
GPIO mit Flachbandkabel
Das würde funktionieren ja
Wie verwaltest du deine ganzen Daten?
Nextcloud nass?
Ich hab ne nass
Ich hab auch Nextcloud für den Sync zwischen ein paar Rechnern
Aber ich mag Nextcloud überhaupt gar nicht
Ich will das schon seit einer ganzen Weile
Ablösen bin aber noch zu faul
Für
Macht da wahrscheinlich eh ne Kombination aus
Syncthing und
Irgendeinem normalen CalDAF Server oder so
Weil Nextcloud ist pain
In the ass
Wärst du nach Dresden wenn der Friseur wieder am Start ist?
Ich würd gern mal wieder nach Dresden fahren
Es war schon nice
Ich weiß nicht wie schnell mein 3D Drucker druckt
Hab ich doch
Ich hab da Default Settings
Tja
Aber jetzt wenn denn gerade einer sagt VU
Ich guck mal schnell in VU rein
By the way
Ich muss euch mal was fragen Leute
Jetzt mal
Hat nix mit Battlefield oder
Raspberry Pi cases zu tun
Ich hab auf
Ich hab manchmal Lack
Wenn ich den Windows Knopf drück
Da lags 2-3 Sekunden
Explorer Auslastung geht auf 10% hoch
Ich glaub das ist irgendwie
Ein Problem von Windows
Weil mein Desktop zu voll ist
Jetzt ohne Scheiß
Mein Desktop ist ja auf meinem Main Account noch viel voller
Kennt das jemand?
Lag wenn man Windows Taste drückt
Ok Leute Dead Game
Dead Game
Pains Champ
Game Dead
Und dann auch Thresh Map
Hast du auch?
Komisch
Mit Lelux wäre das nicht passiert, ja das stimmt
Aber wenn wir es noch mehr haben
Ist es bestimmt ein Windows Bug und wird hoffentlich
Fix mit einem der nächsten
Rollups da
Ok Chat
Und dann hab ich noch mal eine andere Frage an euch
So mal an die krassen
Webentwicklung Champs
Komm bisschen kleiner kurz
Aber ich lass es da
Meine Frage an die Webentwicklungs Champs
Von euch
Kann mir irgendjemand
Erklären warum das so
Angesagt ist Halloween CSS?
Ich versteh es nicht so
Ganz
Das ist voll im Hype aktuell
Weil
Also habt ihr mal eine Idee warum das so
Beliebt ist? Weil ist das nicht
Ist das nicht im Endeffekt
Wie Inline CSS schreiben?
Das ist
Wie Inline CSS schreiben
Und Inline CSS
Ist doch voll verpönt
Wobei ich sagen muss
Ich persönlich mag
Inline CSS eigentlich
Da kannst du es genau da
Hinschreiben wo Sache ist
Ist das
Für Leute die gerne Inline CSS verwenden
Und das ein bisschen ordentlicher machen wollen?
Also Leute
Ich weiß schon was es macht
Aber ich versteh nicht warum Inline CSS
Auf der einen Seite so verpönt ist
Und auf der anderen Seite Tailwind voll
Angesagt ist
Weil
Dazu kommt
Es ist ja kein UI Framework
In dem Sinn dass du da fertige Buttons
Fertige Tabellen und fertige
Switches
Fertige Cards oder sonst
Was bekommst Du musst ja trotzdem
Alles noch selber stylen
Man schreibt sein CSS ins HTML
Also so genau
Hab ich das noch nicht gecheckt ehrlich gesagt
Check ich nicht
Du schreibst kein CSS
In das HTML
Na im Prinzip schon
Unter der Haube sind das
Natürlich irgendwelche vordefinierten
CSS Klassen aber ganz im Ernst also
Das ist schon
Im Prinzip so eine Art CSS
In das HTML
Nur dass
Sagen wir so die Klassen sind halt
Für dich definiert
Es ist ein bisschen wie Inline Styles
Und ich verstehe halt nicht warum Inline Styles
Hier voll geil gefunden wird
Ich finde es vom Ansatz ja auch nice
Ich mag ja auch Inline Styles ja
Aber ich werde es mal
Ausprobieren
Vielleicht sagt mir das ja zu
Warum ich so ein Kram wie
Viewtify oder so verwende ist weil ich
Im Design von UI Elementen
Sacke
Da fertige Sachen habe
Da mit Tailwind muss ich ja immer noch
Also das ist ja wirklich nur
Einen Ersatz für CSS schreiben also sprich
Ich muss immer noch alles selbst stylen
Also wenn man zwei linke Hände hat was Webdesign
angeht dann
Wobei man könnte auch den Serious Max
Fragen der ist ja hier
Massive Frontend Big Brain Design
Das wäre eh das beste lass einfach andere Leute
Frontend machen easy
Hör mir auf wieso der
Preis Champ Prototyp sah doch echt geil
aus
Der Agile
Ne da gibt es sich mit so easy Sachen nicht ab
Wir waren heute auf der Arbeit übrigens
Super agil ich weiß gar nicht ob ich das schon
gezeigt habe guck mal
Also Alternate ist auch
Mit das neue Alternate ist
Auch mit Tailwind gemacht guck mal
Oder auch nicht
Oder zumindest
Mit was ziemlich ähnlichem
Ist das ist das
Tailwind
Oder ist
das was custom Alternatikes
Weil sowas ist auch in Tailwind
drin
Meinst du das ist
Bootstrap
Nee
Nee das ist kein Boot das sieht nicht
Bootstrappy aus
Oder Custom Zeug ja
Wobei Nafbar Item das könnte auch
Ach keine Ahnung
Das könnte auch wirklich Bootstrap sein
Ja doch doch doch doch doch doch
Das ist Bootstrap guck mal
Ja das ist Bootstrap
Na klar
Delta warum nicht
Guck mal
Wie agil wir heute waren
Auf der Arbeit
Heut Nacht ging was kaputt
Ich hab einem Kollegen drüber geschrieben
Er hat direkt festgestellt
Wo der Fehler lag
Wir haben noch ein dummes Bild gepostet
Ich hab's gecherry picked und der Fehler war weg
Also wenn das nicht mal agil ist
Dann weiß ich auch nicht
Innerhalb von 5 Minuten vom Fehler
Entdeckt zu Fehler gefixt
Von Fehler cherry picked und deployed
Das ist sowas von Agile
Alter
Das sollte den
Scrum Preis 2021
Gewinnen
Gibt's eigentlich sowas?
Scrum
Preis
Scrum Master Preis
Nee
Preis Verleihung
Es gibt kein
Scrum Preis
Auszeichnung
Es gibt kein
Scrum Master of the year oder sowas
Marktlücke
Ich würd sagen wir müssen sowas
ins
Competitive Scrum
Ja
So wie es Competitive Programming gibt
Competitive Scrum
Wer macht die schnellste Sprintplanung
Und das schönste Kamba an Bord
Agile Champ
Genau
Kannst du meinen Java GUI bewerten?
Ja
Gucken was da für ein Bild jetzt aufgeht
Viel GUI ist da nicht vorhanden
Es sieht halt Java Style aus
Ist das Java FX oder was ist das?
Es sieht halt typisch
Java Crap aus
Das sieht halt nun mal so aus
Das Zeug bei Java
Viel GUI ist da ja nicht
Dass das hier alles klippt
Ist Crap
Und ich hab den Eindruck
Dass du mir das Bild
geschickt hast
Ist eigentlich ein großer
Gebaid
Passive Gebaid
Das Web Scale
Das Diagonal Skaliert
Kannst du Java Blacklisten?
Ne
Die Chinesen mögen Java
Ich sags jeden Stream
GitHub Trends sind
Sind zur Hälfte
Chinesen Repos
Chinesen Repos aus
Mit Java
Passt auf, ich sag's euch
Was ist Miniview?
Alles klar
Exquisite
Perfekt
Dogecoin ist am Start
Very Currency
Stonksticker
Endlich
Ein Golang Stonksticker
Da hab ich drauf gewartet
In China ist die Bahn ausgefallen
Weil Flash
Nicht mehr ging
Wo sind die ganzen China Repos?
Was ist denn hier los?
Von dem Typ
Hab ich mal einen Webcast geguckt
Ich weiß nicht ob der das ist
Da hab ich mir
Echt an den Kopf gegriffen
Falls das das ist, vielleicht tue ich dem jetzt hier unrecht
Ich mein es ist recht beliebt das Repo
Da wird schon sinnvolle Sachen drin sein
Aber von dem hab ich mal einen Konferenztalk geguckt
Und
Der hat
In C-Sharp unter Akuta
Also Interfaces
Gelitten
Der hat keine normalen Klassen verwendet
Der hat aus allem ein Interface gemacht
Und irgendwann
Zur Mitte des Talks hat er anstatt
Date-Time zu verwenden
Ein Interface I-Date-Time gemacht
Und dann darunter abstrahiert
Date-Time verwendet und dann hab ich ausgemacht
Das war mir zu dumm Alter
I-Date-Time Alter
Da war es vorbei
Warum macht man das? Weil Clean-Architecture
Die sind so clean
Die brauchen erstmal
500 Zeilen bevor sie anfangen können
Damit es clean ist
Ich mein I-Date-Time
Als würde sich das ändern
Als müsste ich irgendwie
Die Date-Time Implementierung
Einfach mal austauschen
Gut, dass ich da ein abstrahiertes Interface hab
Ja ganz wichtig
Wo sind denn die China Repos?
Leute ich hab euch gescampt
Boah
Oh
Leute mein Handy ist ausgegangen
Und wisst ihr auch warum?
Keck wait
Wisst ihr warum das ausgegangen ist?
Weil ich vergessen hab
Den Stromstecker reinzustecken
Massive brain Max
Huge brain
Jetzt muss ich es erstmal aufladen
Gut Webcam ist vorbei
Okay also
Hä? War das nicht das
War das nicht das wo Semper Video gewarnt hat davor?
Haben die das jetzt geforkt?
Oder was ist da los?
Okay
Warum trennt ihr das denn?
Aha
Okay also hier
Erste China Repo
Was ist es?
Mein Gott
Die Ordner
Auch noch in China Sachen
MonkaS
Es ist bestimmt Java
Ich hab keine Ahnung was es ist
Ich hab keine Asia
Schriftarten installiert
So JavaScript
Was ist das schon wieder?
Es vergeht keine Woche ohne neue JavaScript Frameworks
Was ist WhiteJS schon wieder?
Wollt ihr beim Kratos Penta nachdenken?
Nee mich hats gewundert das das Repo trennt
Obwohl das Malware Zeug hat
Wisst ihr was wirklich?
Was ist das?
Significantly
Significantly die Frontend
Experience
erhöhen würde
wenn es nicht jede Woche eine neue JavaScript Framework
gäbe
Was macht es
überhaupt? Instant Server Start
Lightning Fast HMR
Was ist denn HMR?
Refresh
Page refresh oder so
Leute
Leute die Sache ist die
Ich hab das jetzt gelesen
Ich hab keine Ahnung was es ist
Was ist es überhaupt?
Hotmodule Replacement
Ja gut das ist im Prinzip Reload
Was ist? Leute ich verstehe denn
Was ist das?
Redox
Ist das
Ok das funktioniert mit View
Ok
Ich hab echt keinen Plan
Was ist? Ist das so eine Art Webpack?
Ist das Webpack
in nicht Webpack?
Das ist Lightning Fast
Geil
Introduction
Ok
Ah das ist ok das ist ein eigener Webpack
oder sowas
Ok verstehe
So Chinesen sind nochmal
am Start
Java
Java ich sag doch die China Repos
sind alle in Java
Da ist schon wieder iDate Time Typ
Secure and Fast Micro VMs
for Serverless Computing
Das hab ich schon mal gesehen
Das hab ich tatsächlich schon mal gesehen
Ich hab wieder komplett verdrängt was es ist
Aber das hab ich schon mal
Ist das nicht von Amazon gewesen?
War das nicht von Amazon?
Ja doch genau
Irgendwelche Cloud
Native Diagonal Web Scale
Agile Lösung
Hat Chef selbst entwickelt
Genau
Open Source Krypto Trading Bot
Kann man damit Stonks Money machen?
Jetzt weiß ich was ich mit meinem Raspberry Pi mache
Stonks Krypto Trading Bot
Jawoll
7 Euro Poggers
Hyper Opt
Jawoll
Krypto Bot
Laufen lassen
Das neue Windows Terminal
hat ernsthaft 71.000 Sterne
ist ungefähr jetzt
halbwegs brauchbaren Stand
Also das was beispielsweise Gnome Terminal
oder die anderen Linux Terminals
schon seit 15 Jahren sind
Aber die Windows User sind so happy
dass sie nicht mehr
diesen Shit hier verwenden müssen
dass sie dem Ding einfach 71.000 Sterne
auf GitHub geben
Es ist einfach nur ein normales
Terminal was funktioniert
Das neue Windows Terminal
Nur
Ich weiß gar nicht
ob ich es installiert habe
Genau
Crap was trendet
Was mich im Windows Terminal
nervt in dem neuen auch dass man nicht
richtig per mittlerer Maustaste
Copypasten kann
Also was spricht dagegen
jetzt mal für die Leute die öfters
WSL verwenden
Was spricht denn dagegen
einen Xserver auf Windows zu installieren
ein ordentliches Terminal
zu installieren und darin dann
seine Shell laufen zu lassen
Wäre das nicht noch besser oder gibt es dann Probleme
im Zusammenarbeit mit irgendwelchen Windows Tools
Emoji Support
ja wichtig
Ganz wichtig
Die wollten mit
WSL2
Jaja man kann da irgendwie
Weiß ich ob es Beta war mit
Xserver
Ich weiß nicht
Ich verfolge das nicht so
Häufig
Maui glaube ich nicht
dass das was richtig gutes wird
Maui ist ja quasi Xamarin
oder Xamarin Reloaded
und die machen irgendwie
so ein komisches
uralt GTK oder so
Ich glaube das taugt nichts
Ich glaube eine wirklich sinnvolle
Alternative
für Cross Platform Desktop GUI Entwicklung
wird es erst geben
wenn Flutter auf dem Desktop richtig gut funktioniert
ansonsten hast du im Prinzip
2 Sachen du hast Qt und da musst du dich
mit C++ rumschlagen
oder du hast
was auch sagt
Ja Uno
und Avalonia gibt es auch noch
aber da weiß ich nicht wie
wie gut die funktionieren
Also
Xamarin hat GTK
verwendet unter der Haube
unter Linux ja
Was anderes andere
Möglichkeit gibt es ja nicht
was Cross Platform
für Xamarin
gibt es ja nicht
ich glaube so richtig
ordentliches Desktop Cross Platform GUI
werden wir erst kriegen
einen neuen Competitor
wenn Flutter auf dem Desktop gut funktioniert
Microsoft kriegt es ja nicht einmal
geschissen ein ordentliches GUI Framework
unter Windows zum laufen zu bringen
ich mein WinUI 3
WinUI 3
haben sie ja auch mal wieder so
massiv verkackt
bei Microsoft wo ich mich frage
wie kann man es so krass verkacken
sie wollten eigentlich
native Apps also
normale Windows Apps
kein UWP Geschütz unterstützen
Unpackaged
Und was unterstützen sie jetzt?
Nur Packaged
Guck mal
wann es da die nächste
Roadmap gibt
WinForms all change my mind
ja Emoji Support zum Beispiel
Mind changed
Wie sieht es denn mit Unmanaged aus
Unpackaged geht das jetzt?
ja ja ich weiß dass sie angeblich
Unpackaged unterstützen wollen aber
wollte die auch schon zum letzten
stimmt ja überhaupt nicht
geht doch überhaupt nicht Unpackaged
lügt nicht Microsoft
ich hab es ausprobiert
also Unpackaged heißt man kann einfach
wie gehabt eine Windows Anwendung erstellen
und dann GUI drin machen und gut ist
das Problem aktuell ist Packaged Apps
sind so Sachen die man beispielsweise
bei UWP auch gemacht hat
wo man ein extra Code Signing Zertifikat
braucht
und das Problem ist keiner der
so wie ich privat die eine oder andere
Windows Anwendung macht kauft sich
ein Code Signing Zertifikat
selbst wenn es nur 150 Euro
im Jahr kostet macht niemand
überhaupt nicht ein
ok Unpackaged ist hier
richtig
crap
geht immer noch nicht
totaler Müll
keine Ahnung was
mit Microsoft ich mein mal im Ernst
wie schafft es Microsoft eigentlich
noch Windows zu verkaufen
oder besser gesagt wie schafft es Microsoft
überhaupt noch Entwickler
dazu zu bewegen Desktop Anwendungen
für Windows zu machen
Desktop Anwendungen
auf Windows sind
echt der übelste Abfuck
du hast die Auswahl zwischen
was heißt jetzt eigentlich
TOS Terms of Service
die haben
du hast zur Auswahl unter Windows
Forms was ich an sich
gar nicht schlecht finde aber halt übelst Old School
ist und keine neuen Sachen kann
dann hast du
UWP was ein bisschen neuer ist aber
auch schon zu alt um die richtig interessanten neuen Sachen
zu können und dann hast du
WPF meine ich und dann hast du
UWP das ist neu
sackt aber weil du kaum
was machen oder vieles nicht machen kannst
und Unpackaged schon mal gar nicht ohne
Zertifikat
also
es gibt nichts
ich weiß nicht wie Microsoft es schafft
dass Leute noch Desktop Anwendungen machen
und dann muss man sich doch nicht wundern
wenn die Hälfte der neuen Desktop
Anwendungen ist
besteht aus Elektron
und Javascript
WPF richtig sinnvoll
WPF ist
auch Kacke eigentlich im aktuellen
ich weiß gar nicht ob du mittlerweile einen neuen Webview hast
oder immer noch nicht mit dem alten
IE Scheiß rumschlagen musst
auch die 3D
Integration in WPF
ist räudig
gehen tut es aber schön ist es nicht
Emoji Support und neuste Sachen
ist auch nicht drinne
also im Prinzip
dir bleibt ja nichts anderes übrig
als eine Elektron Anwendung zu machen
oder du machst eine Qt Anwendung
dann kannst du wenigstens
Mac, Linux, Windows
gleichermaßen
beklücken
dann hast du da wieder andere Probleme und vor allem
ist es C++
genau deswegen sind so viele
Apps Javascript
gerade unter Windows
sagt halt einfach Massive
was Microsoft da macht
Apple macht es ein bisschen besser
Apple hat einen riesen Vorteil
die machen nicht die Sache wie Microsoft
dass die alle 4 Jahre
ihre Designrichtlinien ändern
mal Ribbon Bars, mal keine Ribbon Bars
mal Aero, mal kein Aero
mal Flat Design, mal kein Flat Design
mal was auch immer
Microsoft denkt sich ja laufend
laufen was anderes aus
Apple macht das auch, aber Apple macht das insofern
on the fly
und ist auch hartnäckig
dass die Leute sich dran halten
also die kriegen das
besser hin
ja und unter Linux ist es auch nicht wirklich besser
weil
unter Linux ist halt generell
die sind sich da nicht
so wirklich einig genug
unter Linux, ja
du hast 20 verschiedene Desktops
du hast die Gnome Leute
die laufen was kaputt machen
und im Prinzip
GTK halt rein für Gnome optimieren
deswegen macht keiner
nicht wirklich GTK Anwendungen
man darf nicht vergessen VLC
war früher mal eine GTK Anwendung
aber die haben gesagt
leckt mich, ich hab keinen Bock drauf
haben sie auf Qt umgestellt
also GTK
ist halt auch Crap
das einzige was gut ist unter Linux
ist Qt, allerdings KDE suckt
also für mich
ich mag KDE nicht
also die Desktop Umgebung
die mit dem einzig guten GUI Framework
programmiert ist, suckt
aber das ist eher ne Geschmacksfrage
ich mag halt KDE nicht, KDE ist PanzeChamp
die Pi Foundation installiert
ungefragt ein Microsoft Repo
ja gut, warum nicht
die installieren auch ungefragt
Debian Repos
was ist denn Schlimmes drin
in dem Microsoft Repo
wahrscheinlich das ganze.NET Zeug oder
das finde ich persönlich gar nicht schlecht
wenn das da standardmäßig drin ist
Visual Studio Code
aber warum nicht
Ach mit den Batches stimmt
da müssten wir auch noch was machen
naja also
Desktop Anwendung ist wirklich
PanzeChamp, deswegen bin ich in letzter Zeit
auch quasi
komplett drauf umgeschwungen
mich ein bisschen mehr mit Web Sachen
zu beschäftigen
weil man hat einfach viele Probleme nicht
wenn man die Sachen im Web laufen lässt
du hast Instant Support
für alle Mobile Plattform
für alle Desktop Plattform
und die wichtigsten Sachen
kannst du heute auch im Browser machen
also so wirklich
richtig Native Apps
bräuchte man zum Beispiel für
für irgendwelche Screenshot Tools
oder so, weiß ich nicht ob man das im Browser
gescheit machen kann so was
ja also für Screenshot Tools
die dann der Taskleister sind, sich Hotkeys registrieren
und sowas, für solche Sachen
brauchst du Native Apps noch, aber ansonsten
so die meisten anderen Sachen
die Leute täglich benutzen
sind halt mittlerweile im Browser
und Leute die es dann auf dem Desktop bringen wollen
die machen es halt in Electron, weil es keine
gescheiten Desktop Frameworks gibt
ja und Firefox
hat gesagt sie bringen kein PWA
Support auf dem Desktop, was halt auch sagt
genau so ein Tool wie ich mal für BDO
gebastelt hab, die die Screenshots analysiert
das geht, das geht nur
Native und das geht auch nicht mit UWP
ich verstehe es einfach nicht
warum Microsoft nicht ihren Kram
ihr WinUI endlich mal rausbringt
für stinknormale Win32
Unpackaged Apps
dann hättest du ne Chance
äh quasi
sowas hier
zu bauen
mit halbwegs
modernem Windows Gui
mit halbwegs modernem Zeug
Unpackaged
und kein UWP Crap
aber
wie gesagt es leuchtet mir nicht an
die einzigen die das halbwegs gescheit hinkriegen sind
Apple
weil auf Linux sieht es nicht wirklich besser aus
auf Linux ist aber andere Probleme
unter Linux streitet man sich lieber zwei Jahre
wer dran schuld ist, dass
Hardware Beschleunigung im Browser
für Videos nicht funktioniert
Hardware Decoding
ja was Paint3D
ich benutze Paint3D nie
ich wollt es jetzt nur mal für das Gui zeigen
weil die andere UWP Anwendung
die manche Leute öfters verwenden
ist der Taschenrechner
und das ist natürlich jetzt
Guimäßig echt
eine sehr gute Anwendung
natürlich jetzt Guimäßig echt
eines der hässlichsten Programme auf die es überhaupt gibt
das sieht aus als
die Oberfläche sieht aus als
der Design Praktikant
in der ersten Viertel Stunde gebastelt
guckt euch das mal an
was soll
was ist das
grau in grau
und überall ein Button hingeschissen
aber cool dass der Hintergrund
schimmert ne
Video Beschleunigung
in Firefox geht erst seit
keine Ahnung einen Monat oder so und auch nur
unter ganz speziellen
Bedingungen
und ich glaube bis heute nicht mit allen Video Formaten
H265
geht glaube ich immer noch nicht und wie es mit
VP9 aussieht oder
nicht VP9
wie heißt der andere Kram
geht glaube ich glaube es geht nur H264
und auch nur mit den passenden
Grafik mit der passenden Grafikkarte mit den passenden
Grafikkarten Dreibern mit einer neuesten
Firefox Version eventuell noch irgendwelchen
Hidden Flex gesetzt im Firefox
spezieller Video Codec
und noch die passenden Libraries installiert
also
das ist Crap
wirklich also
Desktop die müssen sich nicht wundern wenn die
Leute keinen Bock mehr auf den Desktop haben
das einzige was halt gut auf dem Desktop ist
sind Spiele und die sind auch am besten unter Windows
und warum das so gut funktioniert ist
weil du halt
in Spielen nichts
Cross Plattform in dem Sinn brauchst ja
und wenn schon ist es selbst gemalt
und selbst getraw also selbst
erschaffen ja
dann kannst du das auch machen du brauchst da
ein cool Framework was Cross Plattform ist für
ich meine es ist schon so weit dass die Leute
Game Engines als Cross Plattform
GUI Framework für Desktop Anwendungen verwenden
muss ich dir mal vorstellen also da
da fehlt eindeutig was
aber Microsoft
kann es nicht gebacken
du hast natürlich immer noch die Auswahl Qt
und C++ zu verwenden aber mal ganz
im Ernst
das ist ja noch schlimmer
also Qt ich
ich mag Qt als Framework
aber C++ ich weiß dass es Python
Bindings gibt aber da hast du andere Sorgen
dann wieder
ähm
und ich glaube
für wirklich Erweiterung brauchst du
ähm wie ist das
wir haben noch letztens einen Chat der uns
sogar seine Android App
gezeigt hat die in
war das war das
Godo spricht man
glaube ich aus
Godot
war das glaube ich ich bin mir immer ganz sicher
der hat äh
ne Android der Cross Plattform GUI App
gemacht in der Game Engine und als letzten
sogar den den Android
Store Link dazu geschickt im Chat
ja
ja kann ich auch verstehen warum die das machen
weil die ganzen Cross GUI Plattform Framework
sind
äh
ah was leute so
21.35
jetzt off
fahrts gut
jetzt
machen noch
Outro Musik
wir sehen uns leute bis denn